so after Donald Trump was reportedly
talked out of Defending Matt Gates
after Donald Trump reportedly rejected a
meeting with Matt Gates Matt Gates spoke
over the weekend at some kind of very
bizarre event called the save America
Summit and despite Donald Trump having
to be talked out of Defending Matt Gates
Matt Gates is claiming that Donald Trump
still supports him Gates now believed to
be the target of multiple investigations
various different crimes including
possibly child sex trafficking across
state borders Gates is saying I have the
support of trump he also mentions he has
the support of Jim Jordan and Marjorie
Taylor Greene two of the most unhinged
Republican members of Congress right now
let's take a listen we have your back
that is the sentiment I have heard from
thousands of Americans at restaurants
walking through public parks sometimes
just out on the street in emails online
donations and I can't tell you how much
it means to me
this past week has been full of
encouragement from president Trump
Marjorie Taylor green and Jim Jordan to
the Maga nation that share so much love
so let me assure you I have not yet
begun to fight
for the country I love and for the
nation that I know benefits from America
First principles
I'm built for the battle and I'm not
going anywhere Matt Gates is talking
like he's a victim here
he's he's talking like he is the one
that uh everybody else is being unfair
to he's making himself out to be almost
like a martyr of some kind over being
investigated for trafficking kids and
paying for prostitutes and who knows
what else it's becoming a horror movie
in some total then truly martyring
himself weirdly comparing himself here
to George H.W bush
this is completely insane listen to this
clip even suggesting that the Deep state
may be after him
1980
emanation for President George Herbert
Walker Bush said
I'm a quiet man
and I hear the quiet people of our
country
will America First is not a quiet
movement and I am not a quiet man
I may be a canceled man in some Corners
I may even be a wanted man by the Deep
state
but I hear the millions of Americans who
feel forgotten canceled ignored
marginalized
and targeted
I draw confidence knowing that the
silent majority
is growing louder by the day in this
great country
and so I Welcome to our movement the
Libertarians the populists the different
the canceled anyone who can rally around
our inclusive America First agenda what
silent majority is Matt Gates talking
about a silent majority that supports
child sex trafficking like what what is
what is this guy on uh what planet is
this guy on and it almost doesn't matter
but just so that you know
Matt Gates also falsely claimed at this
event that Trump won the 2020 election
so Gates is still doing all the same
sucking up to Trump trump seems to
completely be rejecting Matt Gates
because Gates is not useful to him
anymore saying he's a canceled man you
know being canceled and being held
accountable for crimes you may have
committed those are very very different
things and and that is really some spin
I mean think about that we don't have
millions of incarcerated criminals in
this country we have millions of
canceled men in prison that's the new
term for there are consequences to your
actions he's being investigated for
paying kids maybe for for maybe having
paid kids for sex and he's framing
himself as a hero because law
enforcement is investigating him it's
almost more alt-right than it is
trumpian you know Trump is known for
skating by endless allegations of All
Sorts his supporters don't idolize Trump
for the things Trump is accused of they
either just don't believe the things
Trump is accused of or they ignore them
and say they don't matter Gates is
almost going alt right and that the
alt-right actually will make Heroes out
of people
who did or are accused of having done
really horrible things so these are very
strange times we live in and for me the
most important context is it's April of
2021 uh we're 19 months from the midterm
elections what happens to the Republican
party in 19 months if this type of
insanity continues one of our sponsors
is Magic spoon breakfast cereal sweet
and delicious like the cereals you loved
as a kid without the sugar without the
carbs magic spoon tastes just like those
sugary cereal brands we all loved but it
has zero grams of sugar four net carbs
13 to 14 grams of protein so it's
perfect for anyone following a keto or
low carb diet or just people like me who
want to avoid sugar magic spoon has just
relaunched the blueberry flavor one of
my favorites it comes in Cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter and cinnamon you
can also get a variety pack and try them
all magic spoon is so confident in how
delicious their cereal is you get all
your money back if you don't absolutely
love it they'll give you five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman
and use the coupon code Pacman I've put
the link underneath this video